well after several
uh days of deliberation the jury
has delivered guilty verdicts on
certainly all of the major
charges that those four defendants faced
there were
two main defendants if you like a
romanian
mechanic george nika who was described
broadly by the prosecution as the
transport manager
for the smuggling group it was his job
to supply cars
once those illegal immigrants had been
picked up at the ferry and
let out of the lorry a few miles from
perth fleet they were then driven
to a safe house in in south east london
he supplied the cars he had admitted
people smuggling on two previous
occasions but he'd insisted
to the jury that he wasn't involved on
the night and had no
idea was not part of uh the plan to
smuggle
39 uh immigrants on that day 23rd of
october
last year and but the jury has decided
that
he is guilty not just of people
smuggling
but also of the manslaughter of all 39
of those men women and children
the second of the major defendants was
eamonn harrison a young
lorry driver from northern ireland it
was his job
to pick up the illegal immigrants in
northern france drive them to zebruga
the belgian port where he left them in
the trailer
the trailer then put on the ferry to
essex
and it was a second driver who picked
them up
he had denied all the charges he denied
people smuggling he denied
being involved in the manslaughter but
the jury has decided that eamonn
harrison
was guilty of all the charges he told
the jury
during the trial that he knew he was
smuggling but he thought he was
smuggling stolen
lorry parts and he claimed that he'd
never seen
any of the immigrants get into his lorry
he
uh he told a story of parking up on
instructions
uh hiding in his cab watching netflix he
said
while whatever he thought was being put
into the back of his trailer
was going on he claimed they were stolen
lorry parts he had no idea he said
that they were humans but the jury
clearly haven't believed
his story and the jury was also told
that 18 months
before this tragedy he'd been stopped in
fact at calais
and 20 18 vietnamese illegal immigrants
were found in the back of his lorry so
he had
been involved in people smuggling before
so the other two defendants christopher
kennedy
another driver from northern ireland he
wasn't there on the night
he's been convicted of people smuggling
he told the jury that he thought he was
smuggling
cigarettes and the fourth man just
convicted
by the jury is a driver a romanian
another romanian
called valentin colotta he was a friend
of the other
principal defendant another romanian
george nika
he said that he had agreed to drive what
he
thought were illegal cigarettes but he
too
has been found guilty um of the charges
by the jury um there were four other
people
charged who who pleaded guilty before
this trial one of them is the irish
hauler ronan hughes
he admitted manslaughter and people
smuggling and he'll be
sentenced in the new year maurice
robinson
was the northern irish driver who picked
up
the trailer with the immigrants at perth
fleet
who was told to stop and open the door
within a few miles
and it was morris robinson who opened
the door and found the bodies
of the 39 dead vietnamese illegal
immigrants and there were two
i suppose you could call them peripheral
figures gazmir nuzi
and alexander hangar also part of the
gang
they too have admitted people smuggling
all of them all eight those who have
been found guilty and those who
pleaded guilty are expected to be
sentenced
sometime in the new year sometime in
early january and of course those who've
been convicted of manslaughter
face a maximum sentence of life
imprisonment